we set off before Dawn to taiwan's most
southern tip a remote windy place with a
rare insight into a potentially perilous
standoff
from this car Robin Sue listens in
live communications between two Air
Forces at odds
this voice is Taiwanese with a direct
robust warning to approaching Chinese
Jets
so that was a live recording of
Taiwanese military control talking to a
Chinese fighter plane yeah into
the Southwest atig Wow
Come on is self-governing but China sees
it as its own these flights supply
pressure and their daily Chinese Pilots
are heard more rarely this one recorded
warning off an American aircraft
[Laughter]
they may well be nervous one misstep
could mean war and that would have costs
for the world to understand why you need
to look here taiwan's version of Silicon
Valley
our very beginning of the process which
happened here yeah from here
in this Factory they're making a
component essential to Modern Life
these silicon Wafers will be used to
make semiconductors vital chips that
power planes cars and computers Taiwan
makes 90 of the world's most advanced
ones without it Global Supply Chains
would crumble
it's hard to ever emphasize just how
fundamental a product like this is to
the functioning of the whole global
economy and semiconductors are just one
way in which Taiwan punches enormously
above its weight in terms of
technological development manufacturing
and trade disruption to a place like
this would be economically catastrophic
even the suggestion of it is already
having an impact
this company's building its new plant in
Texas part of the reason is the
uncertainty here if Taiwan is not able
to that is deadly Supply the products to
the world I think in weeks the world
High supply chain will have a very big
impact in waste in the past 20 years we
have never been asked so frequently like
recently you know so many customers that
ask you that hey Doris tell me that what
if anything goes wrong what's your
contingency plan
this is still a vibrant economy it's not
as if firms are leaving on mass but the
long-term view is still uncertain the
impact of threats very real Helena Smith
Sky News in Taiwan